la frappe a douché ce centre commercial
de miku live ce matin à l'heure où de
nombreux habitants étaient sortis faire
leurs courses neuf personnes sont mortes
selon le gouverneur de la région
dans cette ville du sud-est de l'ukraine
la guerre n'épargne rien ni personne
même cet hôpital a été bombardé pour
protéger ses patients des bombes
krasimir aride kova la directrice a dû
installer des lits d'appoint collés les
uns aux autres dans les sous-sols de
l'hôpital
pendant un moment je ne peux pas dire
combien de temps c'était terrible on
était au sous sol on avait l'impression
que l'hôpital n'était plus au dessus de
nous on ne comprenait pas ce qui se
passait les fraudes avec nicolas mariot
paul et l'autre ville d'ukraine où la
situation est la plus critique
la cité portuaire assiégée par l'est et
par l'ouest est constamment pilonnée par
l'armée russe sur ces images satellites
prises avant et pendant les combats on
distingue des bâtiments entiers ravagé
par les flammes
tentant de venir en aide aux dizaines de
milliers d'habitants pris au piège ce
convoi humanitaire ukrainien n'a pas
encore pu entrer dans mario paul la
russie elle assure que tout est la faute
du gouvernement notifs
il n'y a pas un seul couloir humanitaire
que nous avons proposé que kiev a
accepté cela prouve une fois encore
l'indifférence de ce gouvernement pour
son propre peuple
à marioupol nul ne sait combien de temps
les habitants pourront tenir au 13e jour
de sièges il manque d'eau de nourriture
et pour beaucoup non plus de chauffage